woman in Wisconsin is trying to convince
authorities that she thought she was
having a dream when she stabbed her
ex-boyfriend 19 times Morgan Lund
pleaded not guilty this week by reason
of mental disease or defect when police
showed up to her home in February they
found the victim bleeding and the
suspect putting pressure on some of his
wounds she told them that she thought
she was she saw a dark figure on top of
her ex when she walked into the living
room with their baby in the early
morning hours Lund allegedly grabbed a
pair of scissors and started trying to
kill the figure but really she was
stabbing her sleeping ex-boyfriend she
told police she didn't know what was
happening and may have been dreaming
miraculously the victim survived and he
told police that Lund has been violent
with him in the past but said that she
had never threatened to kill him Lund is
being held on 250 thousand dollars Bond
and a psychiatric evaluation has been
ordered now Terry this isn't the first
murder case well someone claimed to be
asleep and this type of circumstance
ever end in a type of acquittal well
believe it or not Jesse it has ended in
an acquittal the whole point is whether
or not there was that requisite intent
was there the men's Raya and if you can
show that the individual really was
sleeping was not technically conscious
then you do get an acquittal in North
Carolina in 2015. a man was acquitted of
killing his own four-year-old son and
attempting to kill two older Sons and so
he was able to show he had no idea what
he was doing and there was a case Brian
you'll like this in Ontario Canada where
a man was acquitted also of driving
actually 15 miles to his mother-in-law's
and beating her with an iron rod and
ultimately stabbing her and killing her
and the jury came back in a very short
amount of time in both of those cases
and said that the requisite intent was
not there and acquitted both of those
individuals so it has happened it's not
frequent when but if you can show that
you didn't have the intent and the
knowledge to commit that crime you can
get acquitted driving while sleeping I
let me let me just ask you Brian is this
an insanity defense or is this some
other kind of defense well first Terry I
definitely heard that story but it
wasn't 16 miles I think it was 25
kilometers but Jesse to answer your
question I think it's a bit of both
because if the person is claiming they
are awake and they see this dark figure
be a mental disease or defect or insane
defense because you are cognizant of
what's going on but you don't have the
ability to appreciate the difference of
right and wrong but the intent aspect
that that Terry is getting to is about
automatism now this could happen to
diabetics and hypoglycemic States or
even if you're sleepwalking where the
physical aspect of what's going on is
there but to kind of quote this no one
behind the wheel so to speak so depends
on how you want to argue it it's an
interesting defense not sure it'll
ultimately work Brian Terry thank you
both so much everyone out there thank
you for joining us here on Long crime
daily we will see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
much